it's Halloween season I don't know that
other people say this I don't know how
that happens I don't know what day
delineate Halloween season I did I don't
know I am just trying to work with
algorithm hi guys my name is grace
Helbig if you did not know now you know
your life is different now hmm it's
Halloween season which means pumpkin
again I don't know the math on that I
went to Michael's crafts today and I
bought a bunch of plastic pumpkins
because they're easier to work with and
they were 50% off so I don't know if
that is something that helps you in your
life with these plastic pumpkins I'm
gonna show you three different extremely
terrifying decorative ways you can
decorate your pumpkins I haven't taught
this sentence through let's get started
did the monster mash it was a graveyard
for this first pumpkin I totally forgot
to talk through what I was doing so I
just use painters tape and I taped it
and then I painted it so there's a brush
hair on this I'm gonna put our painted
pumpkin outside to see if it will dry
quicker and move on to other pumpkins
emojis are very popular Halloween
costume they have been over the last
couple years and I thought it'd be fun
to make an emoji pumpkin I'm gonna take
this tiny pumpkin and make it into an
emoji that terrifies me let me know if
you guys can figure out which one it is
while I make it first thing I'm gonna do
is take this yellow paint I'm gonna
paint the stem yellow
okay next we need a glue gun I should
have plugged this in way earlier well
our glue gun heats up we're gonna add on
to this pumpkin I take the black sharpie
yeah you're all out some of the defining
features somebody say let's go
great meanwhile I'm gonna draw a couple
other features using other sharpies cool
now I'm going to use my glue gun which
is warmed up and I'm going to take
googly eyes I have and attach them then
I need you to match the pumpkin I'm
going to cut out some shapes to add on
to the side that I think will add to the
overall effect of this emoji okay then I
hot-glued my pieces onto our pumpkin
this will be revealed at the end we're
moving on to the next pumpkin in my own
panic of not wanting this pumpkin to
unintentionally look like a piece of ice
decided to add some color to it
so that's last one I wanted to do this
way so I want to lay flat on its side
and these are plastic pumpkins but from
Michael's so I'm gonna try and cut the
bottom of it open so it sits flat have
some tiny exacto knives oh I also I used
an orange sharpie marker and I colored
the stem a little bit okay okay this is
not the right tool I'll shake your body
baby do that gunk I know you can't
control yourself any oh my god this is
the worst haha Wow we did it so for this
one I'm trying it on its side using this
as the face and I'm gonna draw on it a
little bit and turn it into the thing
that scares me the most
I took this moss and I tried to
spray-paint it gold and didn't really
work out but that's okay we're gonna hot
glue some moss on to the top of this
because I'm gonna doctor this up a
little bit I'll show you this one at the
end let me go back to our first pumpkin
now okay this is definitely not dry it's
been like a half-hour but let's try to
bring our hair dryer in and expedite the
process
that's fine enough okay haha good enough
now we're gonna take the tape off and do
other things to this Oh
stump terrible kind of bad but like in a
cute way
oh oh not the worst of the best salad
mediocre performance on the other
pumpkins I wanted to show you how you
could make characters or emojis or you
can draw whatever you want on them on
this one I'll show you can make just a
cute geometric design that's like super
half-ass and you can amp this up by
creating a message on the design I
bought a bunch of different letter
stickers at Michaels which are great and
they give you the freedom to write
whatever you would like on your pumpkin
the scariest sentence or phrase or words
that you could ever imagine can now
become a reality
oh yeah and there you go there's my
terrifying Halloween pumpkin decorative
tutorial I hope this was helpful in any
way let me know which pumpkin you are
the most afraid of in the comments down
below if you liked this video give it a
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
to my youtube channel because I like it
and you do that's it I don't know
I've stopped being polite and I'm
starting to get real I dropped this damn
pumpkin it rolled onto all these clothes
and it rolled straight across and it
landed here that's your mother craps